what is the difference between masculine
and feminine energy
um I feel like feminine energy is like
strong just you know
times like you know how I would relate
feminine energy you're like a Healer in
Clash of Clans so in Clash of Clans
there's like the barbarians and [__]
that gotta run in an attack and then you
have the healers that are just like
healing the guys and providing help and
love to the soldiers
yeah I don't know okay Lord of the Rings
sure healers that's what they are she
looks like a Healer women-ish rolls and
like the feminine energy that go along
with that like
my opinion mentioned open the door in
just like feminine energy and masculine
energy is more of like
the
not in control but just like the leader
of the relationship in my opinion so not
quite aggressive but more like a
go-gettery whereas feminine energy tends
to always be seen as a more caretakery
I don't know I feel like super safe and
a little bit more like yeah I feel safer
around masculinity femininity is more
like
happy
we're happy exactly you're just little
children you're just children they just
want to be happy well I have to go and
make the money and get my face punched
in and lift the heavy weights oh piss
off like when he stands there we just
sit around and get pampered all day you
gotta you see this is why you have to
just just not say things because I can't
wait for 10 years to go by and us to
watch these videos and watch you say
this stuff and and react to I want to
react in 10 years to you saying this
stuff react to our own videos because
you're just just just nuts and and
immature you have so little sense of
what it really takes to be an adult male
or female does a man have to be
masculine in order to attract a woman
for me
yes
you ask for a feminine woman you're
transphobic I can't believe you you
heard you heard this right that um the
[__] were saying that if you
don't want a trans girl you're trans
that's a thing now yeah you're transpho
you're you're you're homophobic you're
transphobic or whatever it is if you
don't want to be with the Trans woman I
don't want to be the trans anything I I
want normal mental illnesses in my
partners you know what I mean like if
I'm dating someone got a little
depression maybe a touch of anxiety you
don't have depression anger problem but
gender dysphoria keep it moving not
dealing with it schizophrenia keep it
moving I'm sorry I don't I'm not I'm not
handling that and but then the actual
physical part of it that a man is all of
a sudden supposed to be just okay with
sleeping with another man because he's
in a dress are you kidding me I can't
see nothing wrong with that I need to be
feminine in order to attract a man
yes for me yeah that's what I was just
saying like you can't even say that
nowadays though if you want like a
feminine girl you're like toxically
masculine now but I gotta do all the
masculine [__] no sense you're fat
phobic or and you're I don't even know
what other phobias there are but if you
don't like I'm as a misogynist I guess
that's what it would be if I want to
submissive feminine woman I'm a
misogynist if I don't want a dude you
know what's the funniest even someone
you're attracted to I just only want to
be with people I'm physically and
emotionally attracted to I'm not
attracted to this person so that means I
clearly hate them for any number of
labeled reasons you know what you said
you said that like the girls that are
too submissive it's like unattractive to
guys you know you remember when you said
that yeah totally disagree totally
disagree with you you know you see
you're mischaracterizing what I said
okay what'd you say clarify once a man
has earned truly with respect and love
and has courted you and you're in a
relationship taking care of him I think
is a wonderful way to show your love but
there are a lot of girls who get
mistreated by guys they're treated like
a second option from day one and they
just come over and they just let me do
your laundry let me clean your house let
me cook you food let me clean up after
you what can I do for you what can I do
I'm not talking about low quality but
that's what I but they could be high
value as you would say but still treat
this woman like crap still not be high
value in the way they treat women so it
has nothing to do with what high value
or low value it has to do with their
characteristics and their integrity and
honor and how they treat people women
don't know what they want and so they
want them they want the big genes
treated like a second option and not
important they love it and she's kissing
a guy's ass she is just gonna she is
never going to win that man's heart she
is always going to just be like he's
he's just going to be annoyed with her
isn't it funny that women love that
though they don't love that they just
think that they can change for men then
why do women love these like toxic
relationships because they think because
they love problems and they want to they
love emotions they love feeling emotions
they want to fix this is yes they want
to fix people you can do anything to a
girl but bore her yes
attracted to Mass
you still safe honestly and it's just
hot it's hot definitely more attractive
to masculine what do you think women
find attractive about a man in touch
with his masculinity
how confident he can be how he can how
sure he is of himself he can lead her go
back to being what I said leading her in
a certain direction leading her uh
leading taking charge of certain
situations being protective you know
it's that whole protect provide nature
um that he's able to like care for me
and like protect me when we're out in
public
um he's a provider he can take care of
me
um also put in that assertiveness that's
what I like about the masculine energy
what's attractive about a man in touch
with his femininity I feel like they're
less likely to see things like me being
a breadwinner more as a threat and
they're more likely to see it as like a
positive thing and celebrate my success
yeah but UF and money doesn't matter to
me because or I guess maybe to the beta
male soy boys they would enjoy that but
like as the guy since you have to pay
for everything and provide you know in a
regular relationship then you have in
money doesn't mean anything because it
doesn't benefit me at all like I could
care less if the girlfriend I'm dating
makes a thousand dollars a year or a
hundred thousand dollars a year like it
doesn't affect me at all because she's
not buying her own [__] I think there's
so many it depends that that could fit
into that situation it depends if she's
making under a thousand dollars a year
but you know hyperbole hell you're gonna
be like a trump okay if she's making if
she's making a 30 30 40. nobody makes a
thousand dollars a year that's obviously
an exaggeration well she's maybe I was
also speaking in her purpose okay let's
hear it all right so let's say she has
it you know Thirty forty thousand
dollars a year if she's not smart and
can keep up and and she's not funny and
she's not pretty and she's not all you
think I'm talking what funny girls I
know no funny girls but I'm joking I
know like two funny girls and it's
because they're they're not hot and they
have to compensate so I'm not looking
for girlfriends to make me laugh I'm
just being honest with you you're so
you call me dumb but I'm spitting
straight facts if you think that you are
ever gonna want to settle down with a
woman that you're not laughing with in a
two-way street because she makes you
laugh You're dumb okay you have a good
sense of humor and you will be bored to
tears with a girl without one okay I'm
the funny one it's boring to be just the
funny one because I'm the funny one
sometimes in relationships right yeah
and it's boring I want somebody to make
me laugh too trust me I think since it's
like so looked down upon it's like cool
to see guys who are in touch with such
like feminine Parts about themselves
what why is that
um I don't know because you just don't
see it as an everyday thing so once you
see it it's just like okay you know he's
not he's not scared to go out of his
comfort zone for something that's not
normalizing this social costume yeah all
right at what point does masculinity
become toxic masculinity notice it's all
the batter girls that like the more
masculine guys just keep that in mind if
there are two demanding arrogant
overwhelming yeah egotistical I feel
like when they're taking over the
relationship it's like unbalanced energy
yeah not a man thing sure when it
becomes unbalanced and they use that
masculine energy as power over you and
they become controlling
I feel like it's when they let that
masculinity become their only
personality trait and they
almost feel disgusted their only
personality that's so ironic coming from
this one where I'm not gonna I'm not
even gonna go down there the thing is
that they it may be given enough time
with these girls they would be they
would be more clear but women can you
know I can't stand the term toxic
masculinity because it's so unfair
because it toxicity is is something that
any person any human being can have that
as a trait I have known some toxic
broads in my life I have seen men in my
life in relationships with toxic women I
have seen toxic female friendships in
the work release I've dealt with toxic
[__] sometimes maybe I've been the
toxic [__] I'm saying it's not fair I'm
sick of this toxic masculinity label
yeah no I can guarantee on there's no
way I'd ever allow myself to end up in a
relationship like one of those guys
there's just no way because you know
what it is a lot of them don't use their
early 20s and these formative years to
build themselves up as high value guys
they don't build any of those different
attributes that are important about
themselves so then they they get a girl
Who's down to stick with them and then
she ends up being a crazy [__] and
you're just stuck because now you're
you're legally married to her if you
divorced you then she takes half your
[__] you're screwed you have a kid with
her now what you're gonna lose the kid
this is what happens this is what
happens this is why I'm gonna have four
wives my mind is set the fact that you
think that that's that's an answer to
problems and not a whole other set of
problems shows your naivete
do you think toxic masculinity is more
likely to come from an alpha or beta
male Alpha I think it can come from both
honestly maybe probably a beta
I think maybe I know what it is I mean
what I what I would say is like when the
beta males take control they don't know
how to I mean I guess it's not toxic
masculinity that's just being a shitty
leader but like when the beta males take
control they don't know how to control
their emotions so they're not as good as
leaders and then they just make an
emotional harsh rash decisions and then
now it's seen as like toxically
masculine because they're just being
masculine idiots you know what I mean
because they happen to be male and
they're and they're now trying to be
controlling instead of having but the
real Alpha men analyze the chess board
and they think this is the best move
we're gonna make this move you go into
the club when I'm not there isn't the
best chess move you stay home shut up
I've been watching too much Tate you're
watching he is watching too much Tate
um so the the men that I know that have
been most toxic were truly beta males
who thought they were alphas and they
were in your face letting you know they
were you are the fight right now bro
yeah bro
yeah that is the kind of guy I'm talking
about and they were they were so weak
and they had so little emotional control
like they they would live out over
everything and be that guy oh you want
to go you want to go those idiots at the
bar yeah like a real one male is in
charge of the situation and isn't losing
control of his own emotions do you see
Tate the Tates and them just getting
into bar fights no right no because
they're in touch with their emotions and
they know that's that's not the best you
know who the only people I see that are
like getting into bar fights is like the
idiot townies and they're like are you
[__] guys you step on my shoes and
that's so beta to have not to not have
control of your own composure it's so
beta and it's and they and they'll
insist that no I'm too tough I'm tough I
dare you to come at me I know these guys
I dare you just keep going idiots what
is the difference between Alpha and beta
males I think Alpha is someone who
would kind of be considered a leader and
I think a lot of the time that carries
like a bad rep but I don't personally
think that it is so can toxic
masculinity exist without toxic
femininity no they go hand in hand so
then why don't we just call it toxic
Behavior
oh that's a good one it's toxic
femininity it's toxic Behavior it's when
a woman that tries to control a man when
she's overly that's not like feminine
jealous when she uh when she right
that's exactly what I was saying it's
just toxic [__] so it's not like Mass
like toxic masculinity it's just like
you're just a piece of pizza no but
women will break down in tears in order
to to manipulate a man no it's different
if you're crying because you're actually
not or something's going on but if
you're crying and saying that you're
hurt in order to manipulate a man into
into doing or not doing something no but
I just know then you're just a toxic
[__] and you you just and if you're
creating problems and drama in someone's
life you know what I'm talking about you
know who I'm talking about you're toxic
yeah and it's not good and you can be
healed but you have to look in the
mirror and be honest about who you are
what does toxic femininity look like
um
you girls know you know what you do I'm
just saying you know there's like girls
no oh my God he didn't text me back [__]
it I'm gonna text Jonathan Haram I don't
even know if it's what they're doing
like if you ever think that a girl is
innocent you're probably wrong like she
knows what she's doing bitchiness for
sure for sure so then why are there some
women who are proud of being [__]
I have no idea I would say I kind of am
one of those girls
um so you're toxically feminine yeah
we're toxic okay it's definitely helped
me in the world I'd say I used to let
men walk all over the good thing about
women though you can mold them they seem
nice girls this little bunch here yeah
I'm not even going to go on that route
and now being a [__] to men has
definitely helped me like put them in
their place and be able to show them
that the good thing about women is you
can mold them like what what did you
sound like a [__] like this isn't even
like oh you sound like a misogynist
because you know I don't talk like that
because I don't I don't I don't think in
those terms um you just sound like a
schmuck no you just don't like the truth
that's all you know what you're next
time I see it we're not gonna get brand
deals after this one next time what next
time we'll see you on a video with snico
I'm gonna I'm gonna put a bake I'm gonna
put it on my channel no because you're
you're the Knight it's the snico and
Schmucker show because that's what you
sound like when you say things you can
mold them like we're puppies who can be
trained you are puppies
[Laughter]
that's the funny thing is that you guys
are puppies you reaffirm you reaffirm
these girls good behavior like you think
all these These Girls if the guys just
didn't have control of the relationship
and told them to cut the stupid [__] out
and then only gave them attention when
they were doing the good stuff that they
wouldn't be different people you don't
think I'm right you know I'm right
that's the crazy thing you guys just
don't like to hear it the fact that you
think that that is unique to women is is
just schmuckeroni let's go
tripping bro you know I'm right you know
like I am an equal partner you know why
would you have to be a [__] in order to
show men that you're an equal partner
like I guess it's the type of men that I
go for well I'm saying isn't there a
difference between like
having healthy boundaries and just
having a bad attitude yes there's
definitely a difference for sure
bitchiness is more about being assertive
yeah being assertive but that's not what
guys like like it's just like you don't
want a [__] girl no guy would ever
like this is what I was talking about
earlier when it's like you're like you
don't want a super submissive girl I
know you were talking about something
else but it's like that's the ideal in
every guy's head no no guy looks at a
girl that's being too submissive
and there's agreeable and maybe
agreeable is really what you like I'm
telling you too submissive who's like
whatever you want and she never has a
thought of her own is annoying trust me
you're right I want I want girls that
will argue with me more you want a girl
that that will speak her Minds not that
she's argument I agreeable but speaks
her mind and isn't a [__] who's arguing
over everything but total submission is
boring you know just get a hooker for
that what do you can't what do you just
just go just go that's that's totally
different just get a mail order bride
who you have to who you pay I'll just
hire a hooker for the rest of my life I
want you to get married you're tripping
you're tripping you're crazy what do you
know you you just know so little it's
just you know what you're fascinating
you don't know you don't know [__] are
you ever gonna get Dad on this channel
yeah when he's retired yeah we're gonna
have to do you're gonna agree with me
we're gonna have to do it uh we're gonna
have to do a mom dad Sunny show one time
because flawed nature and behavior of
men but not also the flawed nature and
behavior of women because in this day of
age women like to be victims I am a
strong believer and Everyone likes to be
victims though I feel bad for a lot of
guys I'm not gonna lie like it's all
about
um like how you talk to any girl and
she'll say her ex is a narcissist like
not every guy walking this Earth is a
narcissist I'm sorry I just don't
believe in that I believe that she's
right that these young girls they just
they want they want a story that's more
interesting than it is my ex was a
[__] so they want their story to be
more interesting than it is so they had
a dull ex-boyfriend it didn't work out
so they have to say he was a narcissist
and make all these problems up I know
every every ex-boyfriend was was the
devil and was evil to the girlfriend
yeah because every guy I know just like
evil to their girlfriend like that's
crazy well the the question remains then
if if every guy you date is evil and
dark you're you your judgment is the
problem you need to then choose better
yes indubitably so stop blaming
everybody else and take a look at
yourself and say what am I choosing it's
that simple are women more attracted to
nice guys or bad boys bad boys bad boys
bad boys bad boys so then why should men
care about what women want
they shouldn't but it's just like like
women care about what men want like we
do no one should care but we do it's
just human nature men need women women
need men if men and women need each
other why do gay people exist
okay aside from okay yeah apart from
that why do women complain about toxic
masculinity when women enable that
behavior by choosing to date Bad Boys oh
again victimizing themselves you guys
just love being the victim
I couldn't even say man like you guys
are perpetuating that stuff you know
like you choose to be with this guy
that's gonna [__] on other females
excuse my land or do go do some other
stuff behind your backs be cheating on
you and stuff and you got the nice guy
over here and you don't give him no
opportunity and then eventually that
turns him into that because the nice guy
bores them the nice guy bores them they
don't want to be with the boring guy
they want to be entertained what am I
saying that's wrong what's now am I
wrong no no not all girls though I think
I just think you have to be careful
because it's not like a fringe of girls
or it's not the majority of girls that
feel that way like but there are you
know a decent group of girls that yes go
for the bad guy you know let's I'm
making this up but let's say 30 my point
being it's not all or a tiny little
Fringe so yeah there are some but to
make it seem like it's all girls is is
dumb yeah no of course it's not all
girls like it's not all but it's like
it's nowhere near all and it's not
minuscule either do you understand what
I'm saying when you make a statement
like got it really has to be qualified
by saying some you know some girls
because not all women want to chase that
bad guy some women are completely turned
off by that when I was in high school I
was turned off by that it did not I was
like those boys were scary they wanted
to move too fast I wanted no part of
that did I tell you about the
Valentine's Day oh no but no so we so uh
there was this kid that you know I met
out and he wanted he asked me on a date
for Valentine's Day it was my senior
year of high school and before that he
was picking me up at eight o'clock that
night and but he showed up at the house
at like three o'clock and he brought a
six foot teddy bear like a full six foot
teddy bear to me on the first day this
is a bad kid right this is a bad boy who
I my friends were like don't go out with
him and I'm like I kind of like him and
he shows up and the six foot teddy bear
and he's like I can't wait to see you
later and I was like oh thank you and so
that night before I went out with him
before he came to pick me up again we
were sitting at the kitchen table as a
family eating we had ordered Chinese
food we always ordered in on Fridays and
we're sitting there and I'm happy and
I'm eating my Chinese food and my father
sits his seat was directly across the
table from me and all of a sudden just
out of nowhere his hand comes up and it
hits the table and I and and the whole
table shakes and everybody says what and
and I looked at him and he goes what did
you do to deserve a six foot teddy bear
[Laughter]
Furious like smoke coming out of his
ears his eyes were red he was like he
wanted to kill me and kill this boy and
this is before the date and I was like
Daddy I didn't do anything like I don't
know I was so innocent I truly was and I
was like I don't know what you're
talking about and I think he believed me
and so I went out with that guy and we
went to the movies and he was all over
me and I I was just like I gotta go like
after the movie I was like I got to the
home and he was like
wasted the teddy bear on the wrong girl
and he had told me that night that he
stole the teddy bear off the back of a
flower truck so there was a flower truck
so some poor person poor guy spent
probably a fortune on that six foot
teddy bear for some girl and while it
was out for delivery the delivery driver
left the truck open this dirt bag that I
went on a date with stole it off the
back of the truck and that girl never
got her teddy bear and that guy probably
I just still feel bad for the guy who
wanted to make that a huge gesture in a
nice way to a girl and anyway that's
funny so then I got home that night
early and this other guy that I had met
like a year earlier called from Denmark
called the house while I was on the date
and Grandpa serafino was wide awake and
he was like who's Michael from Denmark
I was like oh my God I'm sorry Daddy I
didn't do anything with him either like
I couldn't help it he had a rough night
that Valentine's Day Grandpa a ROM women
often are really really insecure like we
like to project our insecurity so a lot
of the time the loudest and proudest
girl out there is definitely the one
that has a
you know some mental issues and
insecurities that's what I'd say why is
it when a woman doesn't have a man she
often has to take on a masculine role
but when a man doesn't have a woman he
doesn't necessarily have to take on a
feminine role
um
that's too good a question for me to
answer personally
I just think that women like I can't
listen up like are more like apt to be
more manly and independent like it's
okay for a woman connecting to yeah I
didn't hear what he said or what she
said don't care
like are more like apt to be more manly
and independent like it's okay for a
woman to be more like manly than it is
for a man to be like feminine I think I
just feel like people think that you
know that shouldn't be true
that's a normal thing for us is to go
through hardships to earn your scars and
to earn your pain and then from that you
become the man that you are and then
with women it's not necessarily the same
thing you can be independent and then
work on yourself and stuff but you
usually develop again those same scars
and then that puts a coating on you and
then that makes it more difficult when
you try and get into a relationship
because now you feel like you have to
master yourself instead of being able to
let the person you'll be with do it for
you my man what did I say about black
guys spitting facts I always fit in fact
always spitting facts it's crazy when a
woman doesn't have a like man to take
care of her and provide for her she has
to do it for herself and that's
considered being more masculine well
wouldn't that prove that masculinity is
more specific look she's got like the
big boobies oh she's got oh yeah she's
got a couple of glasses like the mom the
grandma yeah she's got a couple chew
tree cats at home I could tell you that
you know why it is that women like cats
why I heard this analogy when I was in
Miami I was with a couple friends at the
Cigar Lounge I heard this fun I was like
that's facts because like men the cats
don't just give you a bunch of attention
they're off on their own they're doing
their own [__] and then as the woman you
have to you have to earn their attack
now it's not that you have to that is
some made up [__] it's not that you have
to earn it but it's not that they're
they're not like needy and attached to
you so these girls that get cats they're
the same girls that can't get a guy so
they get a cat because it has similar
features as a guy
and if if the cat was overly needy to
the girl it would be like repulsive am I
wrong you had me up until the end but
cat ladies love when their cats are all
over them no they love it they love it
because the cat 95 of the time is out
doing its own thing if they wanted
something that loves them all the time
they would just get a dog but these it
you you can't even tell me that that's
not like facts all the girls a wise one
all about women who love dogs what's the
first thing they do when they get dogs
what's the first thing they do all women
when they get dogs sniff sniff sniff
sniff you cut the balls off you guys cut
the balls off of the dog right away you
don't see guys doing that do you know
why we do that yeah you make you make it
you make up reasons because no this
isn't just reasons there's a massive
homeless animal population and the
shelters are overcrowded and poor
animals get put to sleep why that's why
what the [__] no no don't even like I'm
not joking about that that's not like
there's a real problem with animals
suffering in this country
that's why we do it stop being no no you
know what now you just proven your
schmuckery let's go well wouldn't that
prove that masculinity is more essential
for survival than femininity
oh [__]
I had never thought about that so it's
all right and if that's true why is
masculinity seen as toxic
masculinity is vital for society to
continue existing
wouldn't that mean that the man couldn't
survive without the woman though because
like we could do the man and woman part
but a man could only do the man part
well right but I'm just saying the man
doesn't you know what what we could do
the man and one oh no they couldn't do
anything I mean Society doesn't like
like progress without men like let's
just be honest like anything you look at
that's been built like ever it's a man
that's that's come on like you you can't
get upset about that like I'm just being
I'm not being upset I'd like you to
explain that how you just said
everything that has ever been built has
been because of a man no I'm just and
you look if you look around the house
you should be more educated I encourage
you all the time to read more and here's
another moment where I'm just gonna
remind you all right fine just cut that
then I don't want to sound uneducated no
bring it no no Mom gets to all her my
freak outs and my mistakes gets it gets
air when do you this yeah all right this
[__] guy this [__] guy what do I
need to read what do I need to read the
woman that invented the chocolate chip
cookie in Massachusetts all the houses
are built by men all the roads are built
by men all the buildings are built by
men all those poles you see in the
middle of nowhere that have wires that
go for miles you're right there were no
female male Engineers or mathematicians
or scientists no I'm not saying anything
I'm not saying there weren't any I'm
saying it's like most
come on you can't just take everything
when I say all like it's a hundred
percent like yes there's some but men
are the ones that just get that [__]
done when you're making a statement that
could be inflammatory you have to be
more careful with your language what
percent of men of Engineers well this is
going to be some this is this is not a
good this is going to say some BS well
87 but who knows all right let's keep
going why do women often attack a man's
masculinity when they don't get what
they want I think that's an insecurity
thing like all right you're not gonna
Bend to my will or I'm gonna attack this
about you I thought both genders do that
so isn't that hitting below the belt yes
a lot of the time when we think about
men who are masculine it's just them
being
uh it's like them knowing who they are
and I feel like if you're insecure and
you're around even in friendships like
if you're around someone who's so strong
and who they are like you're definitely
going to be threatened by that and so
that's probably why a lot of it like
females like attack men for that I'd say
who do you think cares more about
masculinity men or women
um I definitely think it's men 100 I do
feel like women there are a lot of women
that help them but I do feel like men
you know like I said you know about
social construct and everything I feel
like Society is more harder on men and
so that makes them want to be more
masculine or approved to themselves to
other men that they're more manly you
know what I'm saying I honestly think
women I think women are
always targeting men whether it's in a
bad way or a good way
um we're always like attacking them for
anything they do I feel like in this
generation there's no winning so would
you say that men are conditioned so much
so just so much of popular culture has
poisoned us and given us given us this
idea of what relationships should be and
then at the same time they're giving
this women and and Men conflicting
messages about what everyone can do as
an individual what what romance looks
like and it's just like we're all so
screwed up and well that's what happens
when back to basics of just being kind
and grateful to for for and to each
other and it's just all this criticism
and focus on what you're not doing right
instead of what what somebody is doing
right well this is what happens when
when your phone is um when you're on
your phone for eight hours a day you
don't have thoughts anymore you know you
just you just your thoughts are what you
see on on this little screen right what
they tell you poisoning your mind too
about how relationships should be you're
gonna watch a romantic comedy about
people who are so in love and everything
thing is great and they're skipping
through a field together and then you're
gonna watch 20 reels and 50 memes about
how you're wonderful and you're
beautiful and what you want matters most
and those are conflicting messages you
know why I think that like older people
are the most real and they're the most
traditional is because their minds
weren't controlled by a device they were
controlled by just realistic standards
and like what happened in life they just
had life experience they went out and
they talked to girls they were formed
exactly controlled yeah you just you
went out and you lived and you're like
all right these are the base realities
this is how women work this is these are
how these Dynamics go and then they just
learn that [__] yeah and now since
people don't even go out really well
people do but like still their minds are
controlled by their phones so it's just
completely different old [__]
listen to your grandparents they're the
realists other men to act a certain way
I feel like men are conditioned by
Society men and women to act that way I
think that goes along with any anybody I
think that can be a women thing too but
I think a lot of the time women are
expected to be super Independent Women
are pushed to go to college and be super
like what is that like why are we
pushing women to be so independent
because they're not naturally just like
independent beings you know what I mean
like you're not like I'm just being
honest well none of us are neither are
men men are also dependent upon each
other and it's it's exactly it's yes I
agree it's a it's a team thing they're
supposed to be together but why I mean a
man is is more likely to be able to be
on his own because he's the provider in
a relationship he can provide for
himself easier than a woman going out
and doing that [__] herself I think
that's a fair thing to say right but
that still doesn't mean that he's like
why that doesn't mean that he's in a
natural state when he's doing that okay
but I'm saying why are they pushing so
hard for for women to be independent
it's just is it just like the global
agenda to just like ruin the family and
just make everyone miserable is that
what it is that's what's whether it's
the agenda or not that's what's
happening look at this guy
it's wrong I think that if you want to
do that go ahead but there's nothing
wrong with wanting to raise a family and
stay home and same thing with a guy
there's nothing wrong with wanting to be
the breadwinner of the family so so how
do you think we can fix that
well we need to have more conversations
that's one thing
um it needs to be more topics like this
we need to be able to like
I want to say mind your own damn
business you know what I'm saying why is
our society constantly inflating women's
egos to the point of delusional it is it
really is women's egos are so so screwed
up nowadays especially with social media
I mean come on if you're above a five
you're getting multiple DMS a week yeah
this young generation is just absurd
absurd with how highly they think of
themselves when they've accomplished
absolutely nothing yeah you haven't done
anything yet but you're wonderful you're
the best thing that's ever happened to
to me and so and so you know what's
funny is that like me now like all I've
had to do as a guy like start like tons
of different businesses hundreds of
thousands of subscribers I've been going
to the gym trying to like improve my
mental health as much as possible doing
all this [__] I probably get the same
amount of DMS from girls as what a five
gets like crazy a girl being a five she
gets hit up more well it's kind of sad
because that that just tells me also how
desperately people really want human
interaction even though we don't even
know we're we're sit you'll go to a
restaurant and look at any table and
everybody's like this like what the hell
is going on I know there's baddies over
there bro oh my God this is your family
you're sitting at a table
table no but listen to this put your
phone least favorite thing is when I go
out with the group of guys and they're
like there's no [__] here and there's
like plenty I'm like bro do you need
like an obscene amount of girls around
you like if there's like two in the
whole place I'm good like I'll go talk
to them and I'm fine like that's
literally what happened when I was out
with friends not too long ago we went to
this first bar a bunch of girls
obviously like dozens I don't know
probably like at least 50. we were at
the table and they're like nah this is
us let's leave I'm like bro I can go out
there and find full right now like this
is not like there's there's plenty even
if it was like mostly guys there's still
girls that you can talk to and then we
go to another place and there was two
girls there's two girls and I went up
and I said I was like I started talking
to one of them like bro you don't need a
million you don't need a million you'll
need a million broads when you go out
you just find a couple you know what I
mean that pisses me off when people do
that I don't know why why do they do
that they're just nervous I think right
they're just nervous to go up and talk
to them I don't know yeah what's what's
about the having the having the
multitude around I don't I I couldn't
tell you there's no urges here I'm like
bro are you blind they're everywhere the
[__] guy let's go I'm sure you guys
have seen the same thing don't be that
guy when you go out just enjoy it I'll
simultaneously deflating and
demoralizing men's he goes to the point
of suicidal
oh man I don't I'm not I really couldn't
I guess they're just
they want women nowadays to be so much
more I like I say masculine like you
know that whole independent woman thing
I get it you know men of the past
weren't perfect but neither were women
of the past so what it goes up into is
that you have these women that are older
now and they want to start families or
they want to do other things and you
have this bravado about you and it's not
attractive to a real alpha male or to a
real Omega male or it's just not seen as
attractive and then what happens with
men that are not in that situation that
are not as pronounced they end up being
suicidal because they can't find a
decent woman to fit into what they're
looking for their standards or their
qualifications at that so it's like all
right none of these women want to want
to rock with me how I need you to rock
now what am I supposed to do that's why
I'm not even stressing about girls like
one bit right now I'm just like trying
to build myself as much as possible
build my businesses hit the gym every
day hit that diet [__] down stay as
disciplined as possible and then when a
girl comes in she can she can hop on the
sunny train and she can sit in in the
second car and make sure she's tidy but
I'm the one still pushing forward
[__] choo choo you know and that's
what girls like they want the guy to be
like have his [__] sewed together that
they could just come on board and be a
part of his part of his army healthy
girls yes exactly yeah healthy girls and
I don't think I'm crazy for saying that
or I'm evil for saying that no I don't
think so what are you gonna do I'm not
gonna go chasing girls I don't chase
girls that's crazy man well even when I
go out like I hate meeting new like I
don't even like meeting new girls when I
go out like that's so like I don't know
like just going up to a bunch of girls
it's just like it's just cringy to me
you know what I mean if you see a girl
or like catches July you catch her eyes
that's that's what I like if you like
catch if you like cat there's like
energies when you go up yeah and it's
like you like might just like catch
people's eyes and that's when I like
talking to girls that's cool you know
that's the best I can't I mean you know
because like out of everyone like so
many guys just walked by but we caught
eyes yeah I never liked when guys just
walked up and interrupted our
conversation with so weird when I was at
the bar and like in um Fort Lauderdale
like a girl would be walking and a guy
would just like grab her hip and like
look at her and I'm like bro like what
kind of rizz is that or like value women
like who are begging for attention are
like oh yeah with that they are I mean
but a decent woman is not having it I
just chill and then I just have like
that Pierce in my eye and if the girl
looks at me I'm like hey what's your
name baby come here one of those you
know
all right thank you so much for watching
make sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram and I'll see you later
[Music]